الذكاء الاصطناعي عنوان بنسمع كل يوم
بخصوص التقدم متطور سريع لجلس بيصير في
هذا المجال ولكن في الفتره الاخيره كثره
الاصوات اللي بتحذر منه وخاصه من قاده
التكنولوجيا وبحثين يوم بعد يوم بيزيد
تخوفهم من نمو الذكاء الاصطناعي وخطرته
على الانسان لكن لمن ينضم لهذه الاصوات
عراب الذكاء الاصطناعي جفري هانتون اللي
كان لابحاثه دور كبير في الوصول الى
عنده جوائز كبيره جدا في مجال الذكاء
الصناعي من بينها جائزه الانجاز مدى
الحياه هنا لازم ناخذ وقفه الصراحه يعني
فجفري هو احد رواد الذكاء الاصطناعي وكان
بيعمل في شركه جوجل ولكنه استقال من
اسابيع اقيل حسب تقارير انه سبب استقالته
هو مخاوفه المتصاعده من اضرار الذكاء
الاصطناعي على البشر ومن وقت استقالته ما
توقف عن الكلام عن خطوره الذكاء الاصطناعي
وانه اشتغل لسنوات كثيره فيه وقلقوا من
انه يحل الذكاء الاصطناعي محل البشر
الجديد انه خلال مقابله له مع شبكه البي
ار كمل جفري وجهه نظره عن خطوره الذكاء
الاصطناعي وخلينا نسمع سواء
انا
قرب الذكاء الاصطناعي بيقول انه ممكن يصير
اذكى من البشر لكن هذا ما كان اكثر شيء
يخوف في كلامه اللي يخوف في كلامه هو
كلامه تحديدا اللي قاله وبنسمعوا لاول مره
عن تهديد وجودي على البشريه وخطوره من
الذكاء الاصطناعي بتشبه خطوره الاسلحه
النوويه
[موسيقى]